all right so what's going on with the
federal reserve what how do you read
into their 75 basis point hike rather
than the 50 basis points they had been
saying previously overarching takeaway
is that this is the most hawkish fed
meeting we've seen since 1994.
we will be talking about this 25 30
years down the road because it's really
the first time
really since then
that the fed has effectively confirmed
that they're comfortable with sending
the economy into recession to defeat
inflation you can make the case that
they weren't even as hawkish back then
because greenspan was sort of uh mum's
the word generally speaking with respect
to forward guidance that's more of a
bernanke yell and pow fed uh dynamic so
you could also make the case that this
was probably the most hawkish fed
meeting since going back to paul volcker
in the early 80s
and it's very clear from my perspective
that there's going to be a significant
reduction in liquidity from financial
markets over the medium term
until the fed sees the whites of the
eyes of inflation's back breaking
completely
when you start to think about uh
their current positioning do they
believe what they're saying and i want
to uh give you a very specific example
they claim that they are taking this
aggressive stance some may say that they
are trying to uh posture kind of in a
poll volcker
we're serious about taming inflation
we're going to raise interest rates but
then on their own projections they
believe inflation's still going to be
over five percent at the end of the year
they don't think that it'll even be sub
three percent
by the end of next year
why are they saying they're being so
aggressive but still telling us hey six
months from now you're still going to
have five plus percent inflation which
will be compounded on top of seven
percent inflation in december of 2021.
yes because
let's not forget that this is a fed who
i think deep down at its core believes
that inflation is still somewhat
transitory at least that there are
transitory components uh to the
inflation that we're observing uh
obviously if you think about food and
energy prices you know roughly 10 on a
three month annualized basis for or
sorry 12 on three month annualized basis
for food 50 on a three-month annualized
basis for energy the fed is is convinced
and always will be convinced that that
kind of inflation is you know generally
speaking transitory because it's not
sticky however as we talked about on
this program and haven't talked about
this program for six nine months now
that there are sticky components of
inflation particularly when you look at
something like the atlanta fed sticky
cpi you know roughly seven percent on a
three month annualized basis fastest
since the early 90s and then median cpi
6.4 percent uh fastest on a three-month
annualized basis fastest rates ever you
know there are parts of inflation that
are very sticky and and you know one
thing i think we have to remember as
investors because again everyone talking
about inflation right now you know lisa
from an investment perspective you know
has not lived through a serious
inflation shock before you have to go
away back to the 70s and early 80s uh to
get to to that time to that part of the
time series and so the reality is
inflation's a sticky disease
it gets worse unless it's getting better
and what he's effectively saying is
we're willing to do more and more and
more to get it to go get better but it's
not going to get better overnight
because again there are some very sticky
components to it that are already kind
of in the pipeline so when you think
about this we've seen asset prices
falling will they uh
wave the white flag if asset prices fall
enough or do they just not care at all
whatever happens to those asset prices
oh no they care because ultimately there
is a legitimate feedback and response
mechanism between asset park markets and
our economy so there's a couple
statistics i'll throw you to support
that um us economy you know while we're
down from a consumer balance perspective
in terms of overall debt private
non-financial sector debt has actually
risen in the last sort of 10 to 15 years
not as quite as high as it was prior to
the financial crisis but it's still
pretty elevated at about 160 percent of
gdp and the reason that matters is
because we also have a very
financialized economy when you look at
private non-financial sector debt in
terms of the percent that is warehoused
on bank balance sheet that isn't you
know turning over it's you know going to
be sitting there to maturity versus
that's about 30 percent versus the
amount of
private sector non-financial sector debt
um that is sort of warehoused by
non-bank participants shadow banks hedge
funds asset managers et cetera that at
seventy percent it tells you that what
happens in the markets will have a
material impact on the debt dynamics of
the economy not just issuing new debt
but also rolling over existing debt and
that is an issue in terms of um you know
that will cause you know the significant
tightening of natural conditions will
cause and have a material adverse impact
on the growth cycle which ultimately
feed back into the inflation cycle by
reducing demand so this is what the fed
wants they just don't want too much of
it but yesterday we learned that it's
for the first time that this is a
federal reserve that actually wants that
outcome and so that that's uh that's a
pretty significant move